in this work i will explain how we can
approximate the treated distance problem
within a constant factor in subquadratic
time
let me start by motivating the problem
for you both the edit distance problem
and three edit distance pro edit
distance problem the main motivation for
them is to compare dnas
say there are two different species like
a hair and a rabbit to figure out how
far the species are from one another we
look at their dnas and we try to answer
how many changes are made to one of them
in order to make it equal to the other
one
the
better example that captures the case of
periodic distance is when you're
comparing two codes
of course you can always represent a
code as a string and then compare the
two strings
but if you do that you lose some
information for example
you have a command in your code which is
under nested under a function there is a
nestedness between these two pieces of
your code if you would like to keep that
nestedness in your data instead of
representing as a string you would
rather represent it as a rooted tree and
that's way when you're comparing the two
codes you would also take that kind of
information into account
all right so let me
define the problems for you formally
in edit distance you have two strings
you wanna transform one of them to the
other one the basic operations are
character addition character removal and
character substitution all at the same
cost you wanna know how many of these
operations is necessary
we can solve it in quadratic time with
the dynamic programming approach um we
basically introduced these variables d i
j such that
um d i j tells you the edit distance
between the first i characters of the
first string and the phase j characters
of the second string
and then you can iteratively solve the
problem you draw this table you start
from the top left you fill the cells of
the table one by one
at the time you reach the bottom right
that that actually gives you a solution
to edit this sensor
throughout the distance is pretty much
the same thing
except that instead of two strings you
would have two routed trees and then
instead of the basic operations you have
node addition node deletion and not
substitution
and then the cost for all of these
operations is the same
it says strict generalization because of
the two special cases either for the
case that the tree is a star or for the
case that the tree is a path
these two special cases are exactly
equivalent to edit distance so if you
come up with an algorithm for traded
distance you can also use it to answer
edit distance problem
okay so let me tell you how edit
distance differs from three edit
distance
let's say you have two codes
one of them is shown on the left the
other one is shown on the right
and they're both basically a bunch of
nested and nested for loops
for the first code you always start with
a block a and end with block c or start
with block b and end with block d
and basic basically alternate between
these blocks
for the other code
you start with block a and with block d
or start with block b and end with block
c
now the part that i leave to you as an
exercise is that if you represent these
codes as a string
and then compare the two strings
you would you would think that the
edited sentence of the two codes is very
small
whereas if you represent them as two
rooted trees it turns out that you need
a lot of operations to transform one of
them to the other one and
basically tells you that the distance
between the two codes is large and then
if you look at the code you would
realize that
really the distance is large so for the
exam for for the case of codes it it
makes much more sense to represent your
data as a rooted tree
um there are a lot of algorithms given
for three edited sense the first one
starts with enter six then n to the four
and and q log n then n cube
recently there's a work that for the
unweighted variant it goes below in
cubic times so the runtime they give is
end to 2.95
on the approximation front there is a
bunch of works that run in quadratic
time the best one has approximation
factor one plus epsilon
and also there is a near linear time
algorithm that has approximation factor
root f
we would like to go below quadratic time
for these problems
because of a lot of motivations for
example there are billions of characters
in a dna or gigabytes of data in any
antivirus program or there are millions
of ports on social media so running um
so running it and square time algorithm
for these
examples wouldn't wouldn't be
necessarily practical
this slide summarizes the progress on
edit distance
in stop quadratic time the best
approximation we could get was enter the
epsilon that this was improved to 2 to
the root log n then body log and in
recent years we got to constant
on the negative side
we knew we couldn't solve it exactly in
truly sub-quadratic time now we know
even getting one plus theta often is
impossible
the algorithm that gets the constant
factor has three steps
in the first step we reduce the problem
from the two string case to multiple
strings in the second step we use
triangle inequality and the third step
we use a method that we call nearby
searching to solve the problem
what matters is that
pretty much the same framework also
works for three edited distance the only
issue is a step one because the
the baby reduce the problem from two
strings to multiple streams it only
works for any distance for traded
distance everything fails
so the technical contribution that we
have in this work is we introduce
another algorithm another reduction that
also it for three edit distance and then
when we plug that into the rest of the
algorithm we are able to get constant
factor for two edit distance as well
all right so i very briefly tell you the
ideas for edit distance especially
especially
step one and then i tell you how we
modify that for creative distance
as i said the first step is reduction so
we have two longest strings s and t of
lengths n we break them into smaller
windows every window is a substring of a
smaller size and then instead of
focusing on the two longest strings we
focus on the smaller strings we want to
find the pair voice distance between
them
for example these are the two strings
we introduce the windows they could
overlap
then
we put the windows of the first string
on the left we put the windows of the
second string on the right
and we look for this matrix
so basically this matrix
tells us what is the edit distance
between every window of the first string
and every window of the second string
why does it matter to find it because
once we compute this matrix
then we could run another dynamic
program which is pretty much similar to
what i explained to you earlier except
that this time instead of going
character by character we go window by
window so we iterate over the windows we
try to win match map the windows of the
first string to the windows of the
second string every time we map one pair
of windows together we have their
distance in the matrix so we can
incorporate that into our computation
turns out because
the number of windows is a smaller than
the length of the strings the runtime of
this dp is sub quadratic
so really what matters is computing this
matrix and that we do in step two and
three
for three edited sense there is also an
extra sub zero to just represent the
tree as a string
i'll explain that to you with an example
it's very simple
so we start with root we put a opening
and closing parenthesis with the label
of the root
then we go to his children from left to
right and we recursively repeat the same
thing so for the first child we do the
same thing and then we go to his
children and we move on and then we go
to the second child we do the same thing
we go to the third child and so on
now we have a string of opening and
closing parentheses every basic
operation would be either we delete one
of them one pair of them or we add one
pair of them or we re-label one pair of
them
all right so i'll begin by telling you
why the previous algorithm for edit
distance doesn't work for three edit
distance
the first issue is that the windows are
not as strong enough to give us a
solution
and the bad example is the following so
suppose you have a bunch of nested open
parentheses
the way we make the windows if you do it
for this case
except for the middle window all the
other windows would either have the
opening parenthesis or closing
parenthesis which makes them pretty much
meaningless
if we don't want to do this then we have
to introduce large windows for example
for the red parenthesis we would we need
to have a large window that contains
both of them
but that kills the whole idea of
reducing the problem to smaller windows
so a remedy is a notion that we call
super windows so it's basically a
combination of two windows one window on
the left one window on the right and
then we merge them
and we call it a super window
and then in our solution we take into
account both windows and super windows
we make a bunch of windows we make a
bunch of super windows and then compute
the distances between them and in the
end we put these
gadgets together to construct the
solution
the second reason the previous algorithm
wouldn't work is because we have to make
our windows adaptively
so previously for edit distance we
wouldn't look at the strings for making
the windows we just made the windows
before even
reading the input
and then we we would use those windows
in our construction
we cannot do the same thing for three
edit distance because of this example
so for example
the string you see on the screen
the matching if you want to make it
super window out of the first part and
the last word the matching right part of
the super window should be at the end of
the string
now we i changed the scene a little bit
now this time the right part of the
super window comes a little bit closer
and then there are many other
examples where the right part comes
closer to the left part
and i guess what this is showing is that
we cannot decide about this before
reading the s strings
we have to first look at the trees look
at the strings and then decide about the
windows and super windows that we are
making so we have to do everything
adaptively
all right so in the rest of the slides
i'm i'm going to tell you a very high
level idea of how we make the windows
and super windows
so the first thing is that we introduce
a bunch of parameters
i'm not going to bore you with the value
of these parameters what matters that is
that in the end we set the parameters in
a way that the runtime is going to be
truly sub quadratic
the first parameter is gamma
so the way we construct the windows we
introduce a bunch of milestones and
gamma is the distance between
consecutive milestones
we have w mean which is a lower bound on
the size of the windows and super
windows and w max which is an upper
bound on the sides of the windows and
super windows
based on these two we introduce a bunch
of ranges or intervals
the first range is w mean
to w mean times one plus epsilon the
second range is from w mean times one
plus epsilon two w mean times one plus
epsilon squared and then we go all the
way to w max
all right
so the way we make the windows is we
first fix a
milestone and then we fix a range for
the size of the window
we find a valid window that starts
before the milestone and the size of
that window
is within that range
if there are multiple options we choose
the one that starts the latest and again
if there are multiple options we choose
the one which is shortest
so for example if we go for the first
milestone and for the first
range for the size of the window that
would be our option
then if we go for a different range it
gets larger then
every time we choose a range and based
on that range we make our window
now we go to the second milestone again
for the first range that would be our
window and so on
okay
for super windows we fix three things
the first thing is the first smile stone
the second thing is the range for the
left sub-window
and the third thing is the range for the
right sub-window
so we find a super window such that the
starting position of the super window is
before the milestone
the the size of the left sub window is
within the first range
and the size of the right sub window is
within the second range
on top of that the first character of
the left sub window should be
corresponding to the last character of
the right sub window
okay so for example that's
the sub window we choose and again if
there are multiple options we choose the
one that starts the latest
and of course if we change the size of
the for example right sub window we
would end up having a different super
window
okay
so this is the wavy construct windows
and super windows from here on it's
gonna be pretty much the same as edit
distance
again it will list all of the windows
and super windows of the first string on
the left all of the windows and super
windows of the right string on the right
and then we have a matrix every
row of this matrix corresponds to one
window or super window of the first
string and every column corresponds to
window and super window of second string
and the entries tell us the edit
distance between them
in step two and three we find this
matrix we lose a factor of three because
of triangle inequality
but then once we have it we can again
run dp to approximate the tree at the
distance value
the dp is different because this time we
are not just aligning the windows we are
also aligning the super windows so the
dp instead of two-dimensional is
four-dimensional that that brings a
little
some more complications
but roughly the idea is the same and
again we lose one plus epsilon in
solving this dp but because we lose a
factor three in the step two and um the
overall approximation factor we get is
three plus epsilon
okay so
with these ideas we can get three plus
epsilon approximation for three added
distance the runtime is truly sub
sub-quadratic
it's around n to the 1.99 it's pretty
close to
quadratic but by the smaller than that
and the way we obtained this was pretty
much we alternated step one to
get a new algorithm
i want to wrap up by just mentioning one
question that seems to be the obvious
next step
the question the next question is about
linear time algorithms we know that for
added distance in linear time we can in
near linear time we can get a constant
approximation
the best we know for a theoretic
distance is root n so there is a lot of
room for improvement maybe we can start
with getting n to the epsilon polylog
and finally
figure out whether we can get constant
or not